kelbra im harz in sachsen-anhalt dort
ist ein haus gefunden worden in dem in
verschiedenen zimmern gammelfleisch lag
und vor allem auch viele tote und halb
tote tiere also das kind wirklich nach
dem absoluten horror mein kollege thilo
scholtyseck ist vor ort thilo erzähle
uns die ganze geschichte was ist da
genau passiert ja die anwohner
querstraße hier in kelbra vermissten
seit wochen die bewohner des hauses
nummer fünf kleines fachwerkhaus hier
direkt hinter mir
34 jahre alte galt als eigenbrötler
man hat ihn wochenlang nicht gesehen als
dann die tür offen stand und starker
verwesungsgeruch aus dem haus strömte
riefen die anwohner die polizei
die polizei kam gemeinsam mit notarzt
und sanitätern weil man glaubte
möglicherweise sei der bewohner tot
als man dann das haus durchsuchte war
ein echter schock für die einsatzkräfte
denn überall waren tier katar war man
fand ein zentner totes fleisch man fand
tier skelette tote schlangen man fand
eine kiste die beschriftet war mit
giftige bananenspinne die suchte man
auch hat man nicht gefunden keine spur
vom vom hausbesitzer mittlerweile weiß
man dass er offensichtlich mit reptilien
und exoten gehandelt hat und sich
einfach aus dem staub gemacht hat die
polizei ermittelt jetzt wegen verstoßes
gegen das tierschutzgesetz gegen wo man
die nachbarn hoffen dass das haus
endlich geräumt wird komplett geräumt
nicht nur die tierkadaver denn es gibt
hier natürlich ungeziefer in dem haus
und die nachbarn haben große sorge dass
sich das weiter verbreitet die nachbarin
aus dem unbeheizten haus erzählte mir
dass sie bei sich an der
schlafzimmerwand bereits schmeißfliegen
hatte unseren hoffen alle dass hier
endlich was gemacht wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren